la décision cette nuit du juge des
libertés de la détention de laisser le
docteur pesci en liberté assortie d'une
mesure d'éloignement a surpris des
parties civiles je pense que le fait
qu'ils soient laissés libres évite les
multiples demandes de mise en liberté et
appelle des refus de demandes demande en
liberté alors effectivement ça peut ça
peut sembler critiquable pour certaines
victimes et ça je le conçois tout à fait
et je le partage également
je suis je suis partagé en fait sur sur
la décision mais elle à mon sens elle
peut se comprendre mes parents du petit
et 10 victimes à quatre ans de deux
arrêts cardiaques lors d'une
intervention bénigne ont aussi exprimé
leurs sentiments par la voix de leurs
conseils pour eux ça a été une
stupéfaction
mais les deux peines d'incompréhension
et de colère
pour eux cette décision c'est de dire
nonobstant le fait que maintenant on
sait qu'il ya eu emplois zone mans on
sait que leur petit garçon qui avait 4
ans qui a été opéré d'une amie dalle qui
a fait deux arrêts cardiaques et
certainement en tout état pour eux en
tout état de cause pour eux c'est une
certitude
victime d'un empoisonnement ils ne
comprennent pas cette décision et pense
même quelque part que leurs paroles ne
sert plus à rien en fin de matinée le
procureur de la république a confirmé
avoir interjeté appel de cette décision
de maintien en liberté
pour les familles le parcours judiciaire
s'annonce interminable